there's a new wave of bands happening by
facebook but many of them are happening
not on Facebook itself but on Instagram
which is of course owned by Facebook
Facebook has publicly announced that
they are ready to do more to deal with
hate speech on their platform and they
say that they're banning a whole bunch
of different extremists this includes
Louis Farrakhan who is the leader of the
Nation of Islam a truly I mean just vile
disgusting anti-semitic voice this is
going to affect Alex Jones on Instagram
you probably recall that Alex Jones was
already banned by faith from Facebook in
and of itself this is now from Instagram
this is going to impact Milo you na
police the right wing person I don't
know what a term to apply to him someone
named Laura Loomer is being banned I
don't even know who she is but my
instinct is that my life is probably
better not knowing who she is she's gone
and Facebook also announced that they
are banning white nationalism and white
supremacy from their platform so as
usual all of the normal talking points
are being trotted out this is censorship
we'll hold on this is a private company
establishing Terms of Service and
banning certain content then some will
say well but the content they're banning
is a proxy towards right-wing thought
what they're really Barrett banning is
right-wingers well most right-wingers
don't see Louis Farrakhan as right-wing
although I certainly see him personally
as a reactionary so that's sort of a
counterpoint but it's true I mean white
supremacy is mostly right-wing but this
is the same as banning people for other
ideologies that are not protected this
is not saying people who are members of
a certain religion aren't allowed on our
platform or people who are a certain
gender or nationality aren't allowed
this is a ban on certain types of
content regardless of the identity of
the person posting it it is not banning
people for their membership in protected
classes so anybody making this false
analogy that this is the same as a
or worse than a cake baker refusing to
bake a gay wedding cake for example
we're talking about two very very
different things here and by the way I
am going to be debating this with Tim
Poole tomorrow on the YouTube channel
okay
Tuesday May 7th at 6 p.m. Eastern I will
be debating this very topic with
independent journalist Tim Poole I think
the plan we have to do a technical test
later today but I think the idea is to
livestream it on both of our channels on
our YouTube channel and on his YouTube
channel which in total I think we're
talking about like 1.5 million
subscribers across both channels so I
hope that you'll watch that and we will
really try to hash out I mean we're
calling it a debate I'm hoping that we
will actually have a conversation where
we can figure out exactly where do we
agree where do we disagree and what are
some reasonable steps forward to make
sure that there is no unnecessary
limitations on speech but that actual
hate speech and how we define it the
devil is sort of in the details that
actual hate speech can be restricted by
private corporations as is their right
as protected by the statutes that govern
how businesses operate in the United
States so please check that out I think
it's going to be a really great
conversation regardless of your thoughts
about Tim Poole and some people in the
audience like Tim some people don't
tomorrow Tuesday 6 p.m. Eastern Time